بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد كفت
رياض الصالحين من كلام سيد المرسلين
للحافظ الفقيه ابي زكريا يحيى بن شرف
النووي رحمه الله تعالى رحمه واسعه
‏will always chapter name along with
narration
that isquent
and that is that we mentioned
the chapter title inحين
is entially theormentary
and chapter tile contains what is trying
to
صلى الله عليه وسلمخاري
رحمه
‏whatever point taken from the not only
point
that chapter
and thees
of the propet
expon
that chce
[Silence]
الحافظ البخاري رحمه الله
صحيح البخاري
كتاب بدء الوحي
and
‏in
behind the book inlation
الخطبوي
رحمه
‏B
compadion
[Silence]
اسماعيل عليه السلام
عمر بن الخطاب
وعن امير المؤمنين ابي حفص عمر بن الخطاب
ابن نفيل ابن عبد العزه ابن رياح ابن عبد
الله بن قرط بن رزاح ابن عدي بن كعب بن
لؤي ابن غالب القرشي العدوي رضي الله عنه
قال سمعت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول انما الاعمال بالنيات وانما لكل امرئ
ما نوى فمن كانت هجرته الى الله ورسوله
فهجرته الى الله ورسوله ومن كانت هجرته
لدنيا يصيبها او امراه ينكحها فهجرته الى
ما هاجر اليه متفق على صحته رواه اماما
المحدثين ابو عبد الله محمد بن اسماعيل بن
ابراهيم ابن المغيره ابن بردزبه الجعفي
البخاري وابو الحسين مسلم بن الحجاج بن
مسلم القرشي
النيسابوري
رضي الله عنهما في صحيحيهما
الذين هما اصح الكتب المصنفه
عمر بن الخطاب
عمر
رضي الله
خطيب خليفه
ابو بكر
الله صلى الله عليه
‏in
the reward of whatever they intendence
whoever makes his mr to and messenger
migration will be counted and reward as
being to messenger
‏and
madeing
some
of the world
for
his mr is whatever mr to and will acc
in
this nar was by both andl
حديث
are
not all are equ some which are higher
level of authentic others just in
weak narrations there are some
narrations which are
more weak than others and even in
fabricated narrations narrations that
are deemed to
صلى الله عليه وسلم
some
more
and more
than others
and for us understand
we have understand
their terminologies is the متق
‏agخمام
[Silence]
حديث
high
was
andl
in
compations
صلى الله عليه
‏and our
great act in
their reward will
and
a person can do a very minut
act if in
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا